reporter wird ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution was man kochen
aber sie ist kochende wasser weiß was
hier in katar dass er platt durchsuchen
noch abschalten
mit so hohen betrag schalten sie mir
doch nun heißt es weiter im wasser in
der ganze schalter und erst recht wenn
sie blöd
der warenkorb und dann war und damit
direkt vor
sie träumen von einem selbstbestimmten
leben in der eigenen wohnung wegen ihrer
kognitiven beeinträchtigung müssen sich
schon hofstetter und janine zobrist
ihren traum hart erarbeiten
dieser film begleitet sie dabei
ja wenn es ist das nicht lange gut
sehr gelassen ist
sie ebnet
sollten wir
[Musik]
joel hofstetter und janine zobrist
suchen die wohnschule der
behindertenorganisation pro infirmis in
zyklischen altstätten
[Musik]
sie leben in einer wg die gleichzeitig
ihre schule ist
die beiden haben eine lernbehinderung
sie können lesen schreiben rechnen
aber sie brauchen dafür etwas mehr zeit
alltägliche tätigkeiten sind für sie oft
herausforderungen die sich schritt für
schritt lernen müssen
nebst dem schulunterricht erledigen die
wohn schülerinnen und schüler jeden tag
verschiedene haushalts arbeiten
so bekommen sie immer mehr routine
für ihre wg zimmer hoch über den dächern
von altstätten sind sie selber
verantwortlich
ach so ich weiß nun vom ihn ärgere dass
sich erlernen berechtigung von opel
schweiz jetzt eine tour mit dem also wie
immer der mit klavier saigon pflicht
halte der stimmen fachbegriff gelder so
knauf ist sich sicher nicht so wie ich
begriff hey wir hatten mal exciting
schrie bemerkt macht es mir oder sich
langsam ging und in regel hofstetter hat
die grundausbildung abgeschlossen
jetzt folgt die an schlussphase der
wohnschule in der er bereits in seiner
eigenen wohnung leben wird zusammen mit
sozialpädagogin julia van der kooi
richtet der einzug ins rad ein
region
was ich persönlich denke mit balkon
[Musik]
der krach glaubt man schon bald werden
die ersten wohnungen besichtigen
[Musik]
schwerpunkte der ausbildung sind der
umgang mit sich selbst und mit anderen
menschen die haushaltsführung die
freizeitgestaltung und der umgang mit
geld
heute leitet sozialpädagoge sandro weber
den unterricht
und jetzt bin ich froh wenn wir jedem
haus für depression und dennoch wir
müssen aus dieser zeit sind nicht in
jede bestehende jury vor wenn man jedes
thema
ich wollte mir mit jeder schon gelaufen
was natürlich zu retten wenn sie das so
sehen
[Musik]
okay es geht aber darum dass ihr das
schon schön wenn irgendein kleine snack
vorbereitet und gleichzeitig wohnschule
fahren und zwar das neue trainiert
sondern teil pädagogische oder
verschoben und schon sucht das wird klar
der ostwallschule ist ja und das
gelernte zu üben lädt die wohnschule
bald gäste zu einem essen ein schulhof
steht genießt als wohn schüler bei der
wohnungssuche keine privilegierte
behandlung
mittlerweile hat er schon so viel
routine dass er allein zurechtkommt
gerät sie es heraus mit dem sie ihr
wissen
der zusammenbruch des sports mit mehr
ja und wir stärken nachbarschaft gesehen
und sich mit der nachbar seine
junggeselle und kate moss im monat also
man hat nicht so viel kontakt
juni werde sich aber dass es irgendwo
beschäftigung und gelbe säcke folge wäre
und wie ist das wenn sie sich das
vorstellt ich habe mir das durchaus
vorstellen und gezwungen bank zwei ganz
einfach klären ist es schwierig mit
monika besitzen im raub sei es immer so
einfach
auch diesmal wird es nicht klappen
so wackelt ja ja
[Musik]
das stehe zum essen eingeladen ist eine
gruppe von potenziellen wohn
schülerinnen und schülern
sie besuchen ein weiterbildungsangebot
von pro infirmis sie hatte mir noch der
ofen und das team aus dass wunsch und
ich haben zwölf besser macht
das schulgeld von 3600 franken im monat
wird durch die iv und mit
ergänzungsleistungen beziehen schulen
wird mache der muss erst noch der
grundausbildung gott als designer
halbjahr kann man das gemacht hat den
gold wieder mit der schlussphase
verglichen mit grundausbildung auf eis
bis 1 halbjahr herzlich
komme der wunsch hier darf jetzt
ausformulierte bitteschön wurde
teil
[Musik]
die wohn schülerinnen und schüler
arbeiten halbtags auswärts schon
hofstetter bei der stiftung zum werk die
soziale institution bietet unter anderem
haus wort arbeiten an
seit seiner geburt kämpft der 25-jährige
mit gesundheitlichen problemen
nach operationen am herzen an der
wirbelsäule und wegen epilepsie auch am
hirn verbraucht er viele wochen im
spital prächtig und bescheiden glücklich
dass ich vergebung und der körper wird
schwere sache machen und so kam was ins
gesetz aufnehmen
die rebellen schließen sie zerstören
janine zobrist lebt für zwei wochen ganz
allein im see wo die abkürzung steht für
selbständig wohnen zu wollen und mich
also wo ist mein kind hat so hat man
jemand zum reden so dass chemie ja es
gibt sie schon einen christen schauen
also ich denke sie schauen also sicher
so mancher darf zumal bisher so ich
meine den hammer allein gefühlt als ob
krieg oder es mache ihm glauben kaufen
ja in der einzimmerwohnung in winterthur
testet sie nicht nur ihre fähigkeiten
sie probiert auch aus ob ihr das
alleinleben überhaupt gefällt
[Musik]
also sie sind schon der bushaltestelle
schauen in zobrist empfängt die ersten
gäste jede mutter und deren
lebenspartner die 25 jährige lebte
früher in einer pflegefamilie und in
sozialpädagogischen einrichtungen
doch sie träumte stets davon selbständig
leben zu können
in der wohnschule hat sie hart für
dieses ziel gearbeitet
wenige monate nach abschluss der
dreharbeiten konnte schon in zobrist in
die erste eigene wohnung ziehen
sie lebt nun so wie sie es sich immer
erträumt hat erster april 2017 zügel tag
schon hofstetter hat endlich eine
wohnung gefunden
ob das persönlich einreichen vertreten
eine gerechte und gerecht der regel aber
ich super sitz lang lang bis es klappt
62 bis jetzt ja und geht dort viel los
hier wolfsburger fans beruf erscheint ja
freunde und seine mutter helfen ihnen
beim umzug
was ist das wichtigste wir anderen im
rat jetzt und sie allein mit der eigenen
wohnung beginnt die an schlussphase der
wohnschule zweimal pro woche wird der
besuch bekommen um zu besprechen wie er
dem selbständigen leben zurecht kommt
[Musik]
schon hofstetter besucht jedes heimspiel
seines freundes flurin loch im auge wir
noch unterstellt sogar hinter grauen hof
steht und dass er schon jetzt eine
eigene wohnung
ich finde es weder christoph blocher
seine wohl machen so wie es läuft ich
bin von vier jahre kindergarten mit ihm
und er ja hoffentlich
waschen und kochen putzen oder es
schaffen bevor er in die wohnschule
eintrat lebte er bei seiner mutter
sie hat seinen traum vom selbständigen
lebens stets unterstützt was nicht ins
schwäbische durch das sie jetzt gelernt
und mir gedacht ja umso schöner aber
statt verletzt
[Musik]
ja es ist wirklich schon forsch werke
geht
hallo und dann ja eigentlich bereits
gezwungen
[Musik]
reporter wurde ihnen präsentiert von
world webforum die business konferenz
für digitale revolution